anyway do we have an unhelpful advice we
do have an unhelpful advice go ahead
let's do a hopeful advice with Bobby and
kalila okay this one is from a female
listener hi tiger belly cruise long time
listener here's my situation
me and my boyfriend have been dating for
about a year and a half we have no no
major problems or fights in our
relationship and it's been very normal
and smooth sailing but we have a 20-year
age difference no issues come out of our
age difference and we've never seemed to
think about it I just found out he's
never lied with the significant other
before is this a ready for what
he's never allied with a significant
other before lied or lie down
never oh sorry sorry lived he's never
lived with you said I'll be honest
there's a bunch of tiger kick photos on
my computer it's tracted are you I just
found out he has never lived with a
significant other before oh my god flag
I would like to be married one day not
anytime soon but I want to know is this
a possibility for us in the future how
do I bring this up with him without
pressuring him or giving him an
ultimatum well I'm gonna assume that the
guy is 20 years older she's 24 and he's
44 and he's never lived lived' with
anybody ah Nick come on you come on you
never lived with anybody that to me is a
red flag no yes and no and I'll tell you
why so when I first met Bobby while he
had had brief stints of like you know
coal living with somebody he never
really truly lived with a woman yes
Sarah Hyland would lived with me for two
years it wasn't two years babe a year
and a half but she would disappear yeah
exactly so from what you were oh I love
her so what's her name
yeah lady got her arm ripped oh yeah you
slay her in the idea
she was transgender yeah wait she is I
just opened an article and it said
something about she's been misgendered
on the show oh I'm sorry
okay yeah so I I think that 44 is still
young I think that you know this
pressure to have done all these things
by the time like you don't like it when
you're like oh I personally don't like
it when people ask me why don't you have
a kid why aren't you married why do all
this I think the same the same should
apply to men I don't think that we
should consider a 44 year old man who
doesn't have kids and who doesn't who's
never lived with anyone like a red flag
I I don't you to me that's like a double
standard if we're doing that yeah I
don't know that you're right you know I
don't know but I bless you lady
you're lucky you're lucky that he's like
untainted you're lucky that may you
still healthy and lighting plus a year
and a half and you're not fighting I
don't know I mean it's like 44 never
lived with anybody is to me a little
woman lived with I mean of course
roommates here but lived with a woman I
think that is a little bit of the 44 is
old I would do this I would see how he
is like you know you get more serious
and you stay you know four or five days
in his home like what's he like does he
increasingly get like agitated on by
like the fifth days he's somebody who
isn't able to compromise is he like a
super neat freak and it annoys you like
there are certain people that I love a
lot that I could never live with like
truly truly like I love them as human
beings but just the way either they're
too anal or just too inconsiderate of
like roommates and stuff like maybe you
might wanna you know like observe
closely and see how he is when you stay
for longer periods of time in ins home
yep yes yeah there you go some guys I
haven't eaten all day so I'm gonna have
to get some to eat but um I thought that
was a very pretty good tiger belly I
think we should do this every week I
think that we just make a promise though
what I think that we should try and stay
away from talk of
the c-word no we will we just had to do
it this episode because we hadn't been
together because we eat back to lock a
couple and so you know we had to address
it and we addressed it on this one next
time we'll talk about other things
because we should be a mental health we
are going to be a mental health podcast
and I think that everyone is like over I
know also people also want to you know
hear about because they're coping with
whatever they're coping with so like I
think it's good to address it a little
bit but it won't always be about that
but I want to do a little prayer dear
dear lord dear lord please take care of
our Tiger belly listeners and let them
be healthy and liveing and you know have
them enjoy it okay
amen amen and I want to say honestly
guys be safe out there and my thoughts
are with everyone and we're gonna get
through this as a country and as a
society and we're very blessed to be
healthy and alive and I'm very blessed
to have the situation that I'm in right
now and I hope you guys are blessed as
well and I love you and take care good
night